i'd let you know who will hear you trust
the least
marisol asked so you can start
i think i trust nicole the least
marisol you are bored in your life
who the are you
[Music]
just stay out of it like you normally do
buckle up baby it's gonna be a bumpy run
[Music]
this season on the real housewives of
miami
but you never thought you'd see me again
wow it's the largest penthouse in the us
how much am i paying for this 50k
this is the best city in the entire
world
living in miami you can be you and
people are accepting
martinez she's my wife
surprise i feel like adriana's like a
mosquito i just want to like swat her
away pens out out let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm obsessed with my only fans
what are you up to today if you're
making ten thousand dollars a day you
show me more
bet cough gertie oh my god he's very
aggressive somebody told me that he died
while having sex with the men
my dad got sent to jail you show up
obviously intoxicated what do you mean
i'm not i'm not you can't even say the
word i do want to get divorced does he
want you back
i lost my brother and his two of his
three kids it was an earthquake
we saw the spark right yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
just because you decided to like dive
into this world of being married doesn't
mean i have to participate in all this
i grew up in this town i know everyone
and you and your husband are talking a
lot
you left this group of women come back
with about as big as kim kardashian's
trying to become the new king kardashian
which you're never going to be
you're a loser you're going to wind up
in jail if you say i want my time i'm
going to beat you up i'll fight you back
9-1-1 is coming
oh no oh my god
she was preparing for the worst and then
the worst happened
on the wedding day
you